kamel merci
merci à marle aisne je me rappelle
marlène elle chantait avoir un citoyen
comment est d'avoir un seul enfant de
toi
avant moi
[Musique]
je le kiffe mais un me sert cabaye tu
sais toi je te le dis exactement à plein
de fois ai-je qu'ils rencontrent et en
même temps une fois je crois dans la rue
ou un truc comme ça
wade annonce était à cannes tu je t'ai
eue au téléphone ouais j'ai discuté avec
mon frère qui tu avais croisé kika past
et à dia à mon frère appelé km je vous
l'avoué j'étais aussi au téléphone on a
parlé très commencera marlène ça va bien
merci d'être là merci de m'avoir invité
alors marley qu'est ce que vous faites
maintenant je sors un nouveau titre qui
s'appelle emmène moi qui sort le 15 mars
et en malaisie
voilà messieurs aussi tu parle anglais y
ait ce nombre à un coût ce qui est
appelé toutes ces années parce que c'est
qu'est ce que tu as fais raconte nous
j'avais plein de choses après le duo on
a fait un autre titre qui s'appelle qui
je suis d'accord et ensuite j'ai fait un
album de reprises avec ricardo les
gypsies on a fait pas mal de rester
toujours là dans la musique oui et là je
fais une collection de lingerie aussi je
sors une collecte collection l'aja ça
peut m'intéresser
je lis un peu mas-d'azil pourquoi ouais
d'accord très bien riba et coutumes
d'avoir benhaim mesdames faites vous
plaisir on peut lui faire ça compte pour
ce qu'elle est un petit peu ric-rac aux
mêmes questions
moi je fais pas de collection de
lingerie sais tu pourrais tu pourrais
très tôt alors c'est qu'elles sont et ça
ça pourrait le faire mais non moi je
j'ai appris ma vie d'avant que tu
faisais avant fait avec avant j'étais
chauffeur de bus
d'accord il a fait passer le permis pour
être chauffeur depuis l'accord il attire
tout faire dans un jeu pas chauffeur de
bus fait quoi la voie le chauffeur tout
court question fouet mais là je suis en
train de monter un spectacle je passe
sur un spectacle d'accord de quoi one to
one man show avec eux je suis bien
entouré je passe avec deux auteurs
d'ailleurs je les salue
laurie et et fonds dits d'accord alors
annoncé son ti n'est pas lula
ça c'est possible très drôle
maximois exact mais ben alors tu
conviendras voir ton spectacle
j'espère bien
[Applaudissements]